yeah I'll eat this I'm not scared even
though this is 32 years old 31 years old
[Applause]
you can hear that crack in your mouth is
that good
no that was not good it's good because
everybody watching now is like holy crap
heidi do that one of these knickknacks
is you know it's funny I'll tell you one
thing the LJN wrestlers mean a lot a lot
to me because they work or or childhood
toy for me and when I got hardcore into
garage saleing in the mid to late 90s I
could still find them so that was huge
this is huge to me actually actually
like there's a lot of this stuff really
[ __ ] Madison this is unbelievable
because I literally bought this last
year at a garage sale for a dollar at at
noon a lot of Saturday like how how was
this Thundercat in package sitting on a
table for five hours for a dollar and
nobody came across and bought it I can't
like to me that's any time I've ever
bought anything that is really valuable
at a garage sale past 10 a.m. I think
like the garage sale gods are just
giving me love because everybody's
swooping in it what is that value right
now it's like a hundred 100 bucks on
eBay and when I graduated from lemonade
stands in 85 86 87 the natural move was
to baseball cards I had collected them a
little bit it was a huge baseball fan I
was pretty good at Little League in the
second third and fourth grade and then
87 tops came out and it became a
complete cultural explosion and baseball
card clubs popped up in my grammar
school than junior high and then I went
to a baseball card show in Edison New
Jersey on Oak Tree Road at the JCC and
it literally changed the course of my
life I was like what is this you know
this is amazing and how do I get to be a
part of this and a year later I did my
first ever show so you're like
like 1415 years old my first show I was
12 geez I paint like 70 bucks for a
table which felt like a trillion and and
it's a really special show because it
was also the show that I first started
seeing you know just like my ability to
compete with people that were older and
build enormous confidence in me at a
very young age and the way I
merchandised my table the way that I
would spend two hours walking a show and
learning all the prices and memorizing
them the way I negotiated traded sold
everything that I still do to this day
those were very early training grounds
for me and when you're at 13 14 year old
and you've got you know 4050 year old
guys and you know for everybody watching
have to understand a lot of people on
baseball card stores at this point this
was an explosion in late 80s early 90s
these were men who were businessmen and
ran you know a million dollar two
million dollar business and they're
trying to rip me off and realistically I
feel like I ended up on the right side
of a lot of trades of those guys hey oh
my god through Yahoo Sports this is Gary
Vee we are gonna open some old baseball
cards all right Jim Beattie I remember
but not a lot the old Mariners symbol so
gangster so good like by the way tweet
me Gary Vee if you have an old Marin or
symbol tattoo I'm gonna fly you into New
York just to high-five you do that good
this is a shitty pack I don't know guys
the BP around here this is an atrocious
effort absolutely I'm devastated the
good news is there's not a single card
in here I mean even Maguire in bonds is
probably less valuable than my diamond
King go I'll eat this
I'm not scared even though this is 32
years old 31 years old you can hear that
crack in your mouth is that good no that
was not good it's good because everybody
watching now is like holy crap Heidi do
that
it tastes literally like cardboard oh
that's a good one
there's a big deal so if you follow me
for my marketing and business stories if
you google my name right now Gary
Vaynerchuk and Rickey Henderson I put a
very long piece out on LinkedIn and
medium called the Rickey Henderson rule
my first baseball game in 1984 I was
poor I was born in Russia we didn't have
any
it was like a big deal like I think I'm
like I think my mom made me wear a suit
like you like it we were like this is us
like making it in America we go to a
baseball game in the Bronx Rickey
Henderson comes off the field and winks
at me I spend the next two decades
buying all things Rickey Henderson I
call it the Rickey Henderson rule it's
why I tell people to reply in Instagram
and Facebook and like like say hello
he's so awesome awesome guys yes real
pleasure I'll tweet you for salary
auctions thank you thank you thank you
hey brother looking forward today good
to see you brother see you how are you
I'm good good man I love the politician
but I care about the voter only only
only right the reason I'm so mean is I
only care about the end consumer the end
whoever is closest to that wrong wins
right
the end right so for 20 years I've
designed campaigns based on what the
voters are looking for and what they
want the problem is most of these
politicians make assumptions of what
they want they do it's about of some
people that's right they and they pander
and by the way 20 years ago because of
the leap media landscape if I'm running
for governor of New Jersey and I'm in a
liberal town my my messaging may be
slightly different then when I'm in a
conservative town you can't get away
with that anymore right
everybody's filming everything that's
right I can't say one thing and then
completely a different thing an hour
later but I would have if I was a
candidate 40 years ago I would up now
not completely different maybe it's
different angles nuances so you can say
authentic but it's a very interesting
time we've become more polarized because
there's nowhere to hide you know how to
overcome that polarization in general
well from what we found is human contact
like sure programs are like by the way
by the way I agree with you but the way
that people are willing to be on a
computer versus the way you you're gonna
act with that person in front of that is
Right totally different so what we do is
design campaigns where we actually get
people to talk to other people and what
we found was that you take it like a
voter or a customer that is not being
touched and you personally touch them
and you know personally communicate with
them that on the political side it's
like a 17% increase in voter turnout
when you do that yeah if you got a
million votes now you're Christian 19%
it's unfortunate and so I'll give you an
example you know Billy Reed the fashion
guy you people clothing guy here do you
work okay
my wife who loves his clothes love it
orders always go right and then she
wears all these clothes for like a month
ago and she gets a personal handwritten
note
yeah it's from their office she will now
buy the rest of her life
what you got in the corner orange book
yeah yeah write that book then I wrote
in 2011 it will always play yeah it's
scaling on scalability you know why I
would win the American vote only because
I would spend every minute literally go
to every single person until I couldn't
I know just all of them right yeah my
one yeah and I would be like look yeah
you know like here's like tell the truth
and be good and like get to all of them
you'll win though I really thank you so
much you're welcome so we're very
grateful my pleasure thank you my
pleasure I'm gonna hold on - how are you
sir well by the way nice to meet you
pleasure
how you been good man how are you really
well
yeah super busy I know you could sue my
content I literally know nothing about
anybody I know nothing
and I know nothing about what people are
doing I have no [ __ ] clue what any of
the Sharks are doing would I need my
competitions of doing what anybody that
sells business but if I couldn't tell
you a single thing and people are
respectful
I respect Seth Godin but I have no clue
what Seth Godin is doing right now you
know what I mean you're finding
inspiration and drive and motivation
from other sources outside of your
industry outside of your competitive not
only within myself that's it that's it
motivation and drive is fostered within
my own head what I consume is people
yeah the thing that he probably isn't
doing yet all the way is reading every
single comment all of them yeah are you
I think they're the pretty man them you
know what I'd say first the negative
ones and now I love it oh my cool people
watch it 100% yeah keep go even better
especially if he's still at that lucky
place where you can actually reply to
most of them I mean from 2007 that the
reason the reason I did the Thank You
economy which I wrote in 2011 from 2008
to 2012 I answered every single tweet
all of them every email I used to go to
inbox zero and go to sleep at 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning I had to go to
inbox zero and then you know it took
over but one of like the best ones are
the ones I think
Instagram was that was a different thing
the know the thing I like is the ones
that are coming on you guys this guy's a
charlatan he's full of [ __ ] because we
have we have bravado so you're gonna get
that and honestly I have empathy like if
you're somebody especially LinkedIn
LinkedIn is probably where I get my most
hate because it's professional and I'm
not delivering that with my content but
I'm doing that because the message is
right the information is right I
understand that I'm not wearing a suit
and tie I understand I'm cursing I have
empathy I'm very much in this I have
respect if you're 62 year old Charlie
and you grew up a certain way where the
eff were [ __ ] is disrespectful who might
the judge
here that's 2018 I don't care that it's
cool now like whatever like that's your
world and I respect that and I'll jump
in and say hey brother I I just I see
the comment like you know I get it and
like if you were I'll say what I just
said if you were brought up in a certain
way I can understand that but like if
you can we agree that if we get past
that do you see where I'm going with
this or I'm sorry I bothered you or
thinks that nature I wouldn't I would
highly recommend engage more you should
instead of saying [ __ ] you I'll show you
you need to say I hear you respect but
here's why or how or what and you'll be
stunned I would argue that if you did it
for next six months to see what he's
like I can think off the top of my head
so many of some of the people that have
become real advocates of my work behind
the scenes are people that start off not
liking me yeah yeah and you know what it
is it's it's respecting it's not getting
too high on your own supply like I'm
always gonna read that [ __ ] and respond
because I never want to think I'm always
right or I'm so great like like all the
success is not gonna make me think that
I'm not that today is not the day that I
have a point of view that's wrong I
guess not you handling the impact of the
emotion when the perfect and the people
that are close to you bring that sort of
negativity your way I try to forget
about the straight yeah I got a tweet
from a mic stand point I feel bad for
them yeah because they're something
waiter so I try to understand it'll give
you a good sample how about my dad my
dad up until probably three years ago
competed directly with me in our own
business like I'm a cab I like make it
like like compete it you know and not in
a healthy way but I get it because I'm
gonna do that to my kids too like I get
it because he's overly competitive it's
also probably the single trait that he
gave me that I'm most thankful for above
everything else above everything else
that my dad gave me he gave and you've
maybe heard my schpeel honor which
really [ __ ] saved me if I had to give
up on her which is [ __ ] noble as [ __ ]
and has made me a much better dude
I'd still keep competitiveness because
it is the [ __ ] fuel that everything
like I would just not be anywhere in the
same universe of Who I am without it
which is why when I like it but it's in
me like I don't like I like when other
people win which is a little bit
different because my big thing is like
well they deserved it like most people
hate when people win and they say they
get lucky
I see somebody win as long as they're
not a criminal and like stealing sure
I'm like she deserved it she [ __ ]
deserved it she was either smarter or
grinded harder both I don't think like
I've worked 15 years and this guy came
along and got big good two seconds well
he was smart enough to really in you
know what you only people have consumed
my content a fuckload you know many
people have gone pot committed very few
you know what the ratio of the people
that have gone cop pop committed all of
them have won all of them because it's
just basic math of attention yeah I
create no vulnerability I'm not guessing
if Barrow is gonna be big and that's
what everybody starts doing they start
getting into personality traits and they
start guessing if I could tell you
anything can I tell you what happened to
me
from your point where you are now and
your career to what where I'm sitting
now or sighs well I got I got an hour or
I got narrower I guess and I know you
get it because you feel the pressure
that wait a minute said a lot of the
same stuff people are watching and and
you feel this pull to like let me I
think this is right there I've gotten I
mean you know a lot of times you know
people will say my cuz I read my
comments you know [ __ ] Gary like to go
my Instagram yeah this guy says the same
[ __ ] every day and I jump in I'm like
yep yeah until the end [ __ ]
there's things I believe in like what do
you want for me I'm not gonna make [ __ ]
up but it's all about going more narrow
for you now yeah that's where to succeed
because every minute you spend not being
an arrow is a minute you're not spending
getting your team to make more content
for the thing and I think that's what I
mean I should say I'm the best
it's without love best I love taking
someone who's clueless and just walking
them through and then the biggest win is
I got a job you did it that's [ __ ]
huge - and you know what's great about
what you do there's a black and white
short term ROI I didn't have a job
ya know I'm a job yeah yeah right yeah
you know when you do branding like the
[ __ ] that you know takes three four five
years sometimes so it's a little tricky
last thing is that sorry I've been
listening to your voice saying when I
start doing what you start said hey
remind me to call home in and out same
way tonight and now don't miss call it
beeps flashes you know so I could see
that being as you keep saying the next
thing it's gonna be the next thing cool
man
so like literally like like now you have
to level up you should build an Alexa
skill called how to get a job you know
and then when under than it goes 365
days a year will give you one tip on
Alexa
yeah sure can not yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]